- [Narrator] In southern central Bosnia,
just outside the town of Konjic
and behind a quiet unassuming
building in the mountains
lies a secret place,
a place designed to survive
a nuclear apocalypse.
Welcome to Tito's Bunker.
(light mysterious music)
Construction of the bunker was
started by Josip Broz Tito,
the president of Yugoslavia
at the height of the Cold War.
It took 26 years to complete
and was a well-kept
top secret for decades.
The horseshoe-shaped structure
goes over 600 feet deep
into the mountain and
is a maze of offices,
conferences rooms, doors,
as well as living quarters
for Tito and his wife.
In the event of a nuclear strike,
the bunker could protect 350
of the most important political
and military persons in the country.
The bunker was almost
destroyed in the early '90s
during the Bosnian War,
but went untouched,
remaining a time capsule
from the Cold War,
its bedrooms, bathrooms,
phones, and typewriters
still lying ready for atomic war.
Today, the bunker serves
a more peaceful purpose
as a modern art museum, housing
one of the most important
and valuable art collections
in southern Europe.
Built for war between East and West,
Tito's Bunker is now a safe
haven for creative works
from artists from around the world.